Dok market investors have been enjoying
the longest bull market in Wall Street
history but the bull stumbled badly
earlier in the week before making a
slight comeback on Friday all three of
the major indexes posted losses of up to
four percent for the week the worst
five-day run in six months here's with
more on what's behind the big sell-off
and more in CBS news
senior business analyst Jill Schlesinger
Jill good morning good morning so we're
not used to turbulence but now we're
suddenly in a little rough patch here
what's going on
well you know we had turbulence earlier
in the year back in February we actually
had a correction a ten percent drop from
the recent top but then things were
pretty mellow and what has started to
happen is it's actually this fear that
interest rates will keep rising now
that's sort of a weird thing to concern
supposed to in a good economy right it's
a sign that things are good right now so
the feds been raising interest rates but
now other interest rates that are really
based on supply and demand in the
marketplace they're starting to rise so
we have the two year Treasury the
10-year Treasury rising to multi-year
highs what does that do it makes the
cost of borrowing for us for a mortgage
a car makes it more expensive also makes
corporate borrowing more expensive maybe
eats into profitability for stocks and
finally what it does is it gives you the
impetus to say hey maybe if I've made a
ton of money in technology stocks I'll
sell some of those and move it over into
the bond market where I'm gonna make
three three and a quarter percent so
what should we do first thing I asked
you on Friday
should I do this I love that because it
is a scary time so there's a few
different ways to think about this one
is wow I forgot how risky the stock
market could be and I'm freaked out and
if that's the case what kind of investor
are you really do you need this money
within the next year if you do maybe
it's a tuition or a home down payment on
a home or a car you've got to get that
money out of the risky stock market but
if you're just kind of freaked out and
you forgot that it is risky and if
you're going to actually change your
allocation and make a shift be sure not
to then just sort of change it again
once the market goes up that's a bad
cycle for
most of us we are actually investing for
the long term you don't have to mess
with your game plan
stick to the diversified portfolio it
got you through in February and now
it'll get you through again President
Trump had some strong words for the
Federal Reserve saying they had gone
quote Loco for continuing to raise the
interest rates but you just said isn't
this a good sign
yeah it's very curious because remember
President Trump appointed the new Fed
chair Jerome Powell and really what is
Powell's job as Fed chair to marshal up
all the Fed officials and say what's
going on in the economy the feds got two
big jobs it's called a dual mandate
create an economic environment that
fosters job growth well we've got 49
year lows in the unemployment rate but
don't have the economy heat up so much
that we start to see inflation eat away
at our progress that's what the Fed is
doing they're normalizing their policies
to try to get interest rates high enough
for no inflation but then again they
don't want to let things heat up too
much oh so much to talk about Jill and
you're the one to talk to
anytime Jill Schlesinger thank you